Welcome to Google Developers
Weekly for October 14, 2013.
I'm Louis Gray, and this is our
highlight reel of what's
happening in the world
of Google Developers
on the set and off.
If you're building an enterprise
web app, you'll
want to use the Google Places
API to give your users the
right information and
how to get there.
Dylan Thomas and Dave McClusky
from the Geo team talk to us
about the best ways to find
yourself using this API.
We're especially excited this
week to talk about the return
of Google Summer of Code.
This is the 10th year we've
connected students with real
world open source software
development projects.
Since 2005, Summer of Coders
have produced more than 50
million lines of code,
with participants
in nearly 100 countries.
From the open source team, Cat
Allman takes us through this
year's plan.
Also announced this week is
Google Code-in for 2013, a
global online contest
introducing pre-university
students to the world of open
source software development.
Check out the program site
at google-melange, that's
M-E-L-A-N-G-E, .com
to learn more.
The contest begins
November 18.
Cat Allman and Stephanie
Taylor join us
on a special GDL.
And a recurring theme in our GDL
weekly recordings has been
a focus on the cloud.
Jonathan Simon says how we can
get started with the Google
Compute Engine load balancing.
And Dylan Thomas came back to
the studio to talk to us about
what's new in enterprise maps.
Ajay Hemnani joined Dylan as
they discussed GME domain
provisioning, vector editing,
and other updates.
Google Cloud platform is for
all developers, including
those working on iOS.
This week, we announced
mobile back end
starter, or NBS, for iOS.
NBS jumpstarts iOS apps with
cloud data stores,
device-to-device push
notifications, and much more.
And because NBS is based on App
Engine, you can scale to
support hundreds of users
at no charge.
This week, the Dart team
released a new tutorial that
uses a Polymer web component
library.
This tutorial shows you how to
create custom HTML elements
with Polymer.
Along the way, you'll learn how
to include Polymer in your
apps for starters.
And then we'll show you
everything else you need to
add to your custom elements.
And to also make sure that you
never miss a thing from the
world of Google Developers,
subscribe to Google Developers
on YouTube, and check out
the GDL schedule at
developers.google.com/live.
I'm Louis Gray, and I'll
see you in the studio.